hi welcome to wacky gamer Hey
hi hi beard again yeah weird it's like
we filmed those videos a month ago so
today I'm wacky game we're gonna be
talking about some of your suggestions
for nerd wars indeed you guys like the
format of the WTF Edition so we're gonna
stick with that and we're just gonna go
through a bunch of them and see what
comes out of our mouths
yay what kinda dirty you drink the flash
versus Sonic the Hedgehog flash fastest
man alive
mmm he actually transcends time yeah
Sonic collects rings I say Sonic what
he's got all that gold I mean he'll buy
some weaponry to kill the flash yeah
actually no it's gonna be the flash
thank you yeah that's the flash can just
rewind time until he goes back before
Sonic bought the weapons and then cap
some Sonic is beaten by a wall the flash
can vibrate his body so much that he can
go through salad matter yeah so we're
gonna have to go with snarf on that one
next up snarf versus the Ewoks now snarf
being the annoying guy from the
Thundercats versus an Ewok being the
annoying guys from Return of the Jedi
huh
would everybody watch that how are we
defining who wins i refine who would win
in a fight or who would annoy people the
most you know I don't I don't even think
that we should we should do it who wins
I want to know about the circumstances
of the it's a fight to the death and
they both have to die I think that's the
thing I'm gonna have to give it to the
Ewoks cuz they have Spears I've never
seen snarf carry a weapon RF doesn't
carry a weapon so yeah I guess you'd
have to give it to the he was the Ewoks
the only one with the pointy thing but
but you'd hope that somehow they screw
up enough to impale both of themselves
maybe that you'd be dumb enough to like
stick the spear in the ground and then
they just both jump on it yeah that
would be nice a victory condition nice
for both of them oh you know a next up
shredder versus dr. doom really dr. doom
is kind of an idiot are we every talkin
out of Von Doom or my my physician no
we're talking about Autobahn do okay cuz
my doctor is kind of stupid you have a
doctor named doctor do ya that's why I
went I spelled with an e at the end
isn't it it's Ted's do eme but it's
German so it's doom okay here's the
thing I know dr. Newman the shredder
look a little similar the shuddering
metal yeah now again for those who don't
know shredder from Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles yeah Von Doom from comic books
right okay shredder couldn't beat some
pubescent teenaged turtles and how was
he going to bend there die rat doom he
gets so upset about this I would
actually make an argument for shredder
well how are you gonna do it and bebop
and Rocksteady and just distract the Von
Doom or dr. doom so much dr. doom is
gonna get pissed off and kill himself
okay all right I guess suicide based on
you know
annoying how how badly the the TV series
ruined the comic book
series was awesome like a comic-con is
awesome right it is true even though it
was black and white but it's black and
white
who cares get past that initially it's
like I need color I can't imagine
anything if it's just shades of grey
let's move on okay the last one
Rorschach or Watchmen Rorschach he's the
guy with the white mask and the black
patterns that move all over it versus
the Punisher this is a comic really good
fight this is actually really good one
maybe we'll do a full one maybe not but
maybe we'll do I could talk about this
forever I who do you think Jeff who do
you think see I know more Rorschach than
punisher in his I would have to side
with war shock only because I go with
what I know
yeah but Rorschach I think is in my mind
a little crazier a little more unstable
and more than would pull something out
of his ass that that Punisher Punisher
just seems to work on range where
Rorschach is a little bit of like well
yeah the thing is you know Rorschach
just uses what's in his environment
whereas the Punisher uses the weapons he
brings to a fight and the environment so
I think really the thing is like where
are they fighting yeah and you know in
our jungle if they were fighting in the
woods I'd give it to the punish yeah I
probably would too if they're fighting
on the ceiling or an office building
yeah I'd probably give it to Rorschach
that being said I'd want to see bro Shaq
with that being said I would just like
to see somebody film that fight I would
I would love if somebody can make that
happen out there you know that would be
one of those epic like cinematic moments
why don't they have just a Rorschach
comic book let's go write it
check us out back again we've got some
videos in the comments thumbs up my god
Rorschach it's gonna be awesome
get in man we're gonna give is it copy
written I don't think it is alright good